DAS ist wirklich der Hammer: Fast zeitgleich
haben zwei Forschungsteams aus Deutschland
und Norwegen einen Akku auf Silizium-Basis
gebaut, der im Vergleich zu den gewöhnlichen
Lithium-Ionen-Technik weit mehr kann.
Der neuartige Akku aus Deutschland beispielsweise
weist die zehnfache Ladekapazität auf und
auch sein Ladevorgang dauert nur wenige Minuten.
What?
Clixoom Science & Fiction Heir gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts Los gehts
und vielen Dank für Euren Themenvorschlag
aus der Whats App Community!
Herzlich willkommen.
Wer kennt es nicht: Nur noch drei Prozent
Akku!
Und das natürlich immer in ungünstigen Situationen:
Beispielsweise dann, wenn man einen wichtigen
Anruf machen muss oder aber noch eine dringende
Nachricht verschicken will.
Der Traum von allen Handynutzern : eine lange
Akkulaufzeit - kombiniert mit einer kurzen
Ladezeit!
Ähnlich ergeht es wohl allen Nutzern von
Elektroautos!
Und diese Träume könnten vielleicht bald
Wirklichkeit werden - eine Erfindung aus Deutschland
macht jetzt Hoffnung darauf.
Ein Forschungsteam aus Kiel hat einen Akku
auf der Basis von Silizium gebaut und das
Ergebnis ist vielversprechend.
Bisher setzt man in der Batterie-Technik auf
Graphit-Anoden.
Doch bei diesem neuartigen Akku wurde als
Anodenmaterial Silizium verbaut.
Und es ist tatsächlich ideal dafür geeignet,
denn es speichert deutlich mehr Energie als
Graphit.
500 Ladungen und Entladungen hat das Forschungsteam
bereits vorgenommen und gezeigt, dass der
Aufladevorgang gerade einmal zwölf Minuten
dauert.
Ein entsprechender Akku, der auf der Lithium-Ionen-Technik
basiert, würde fünf Stunden brauchen.
Silizium ist in der Erdhülle - nach Sauerstoff
- das zweithäufigste Element: Es ist also
breit verfügbar und hat äußerst günstige
Materialeigenschaften.
Beispielsweise ist es fllammhemmend, was einen
weiteren Pluspunkt in der Batterietechnik
darstellt.
Das größte Problem dagegen bestand für
das Forschungsteam aus der mechanischen Instabilität
des Siliziums.
Denn beim Laden dehnt es sich um 400 Prozent
aus und kann so schnell zerbrechen.
Das alles basiert auf seiner hohen Energiedichte,
sodass besonders viele Lithium-Ionen aufgenommen
werden.
Doch wie genau hat das Forschungsteam diese
Herausforderung gelöst?
Sie brachten das Silizium in die Mikrostruktur
eines dünnes Drahtes.
So war es flexibel und konnte die starke Ausdehnung
gut überstehen.
Schon länger haben Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler im Bereich der Elektromobilität
Silizium als großen Hoffnungsträger identifiziert.
Denn na klar: Elektroautos hätten so eine
deutlich höhere Reichweite.
Aber auch das Problem mit den Handy-Akkus
könnte so bald der Vergangenheit angehören
und auch andere batteriebetriebene Produkte
könnten optimiert werden.
Beispielsweise Hörgeräte, die so weiter
verkleinert werden könnte.
Nun sind die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
aus Kiel daran, auch die Kathode weiter zu
optimieren.
Die Idee ist es, sie aus Schwefel zu bauen
und so die Speicherkapazität des Akkus weiter
zu maximieren.
Das alles wäre ein riesiger Fortschritt und
fast zu schön, um wahr zu sein.
Denn diese Idee ist nicht nur im Sinne der
Forscher und der Nutzer, sondern auch im Sinne
der Umwelt.
Um dann aber wirklich auch einen Durchbruch
in der Akkutechnologie darzustellen, müsste
dann jedoch auch der Sprung vom Forschungslabor
in die industrielle Fertigung gelingen.
Uuuuund: Fast zeitgleich zu dem Forschungsteam
aus Kiel haben auch Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler aus Norwegen an diesem Konzept
getüftelt.
Hier ist die Projekt schon soweit fortgeschritten,
dass die Technologie nun patentiert werden
soll und industrielle Tests anstehen.
Auch bei der norwegischen Arbeit ging es darum,
Silizium endlich in größeren Mengen als
Anodenmaterial verbauen zu können - und dass
trotz seiner enormen Ausdehnung beim Ladevorgang.
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
haben das durch die Kombination von Graphit
und Silizium geschafft.
So wurde die Maximierung des Silizium-Anteils
erreicht und durch den Graphit-Anteil zugleich
eine radikale Ausdehnung verhindert.
Auch dieses Projekt würde beispielsweise
die Elektromobilität revolutionieren: Zukünftige
Elektroauto könnten rund 1000 Kilometer zurücklegen
- mit nur einer Aufladung.
Und auch Smartphones könnten tagelang laufen.
Doch bis wir davon dann im Alltag tatsächlich
profitieren, werden wir uns bestimmt auch
noch einige Jahre gedulden müssen.
Ich kriege echt ein bisschen Gänsehaut, wenn
ich an die Zukunft mit solchen Akkus denke.
Und Gänsehat, die gibt es auch bei dieser
Videopremiere auf dem englischen Clixoomkanal:
Smaller than a grain of rice - the tiniest
computer on earth Ich freue mich auf euch
auf dem englischen Kanal.
See you soon - stay tuned!